i feel like your perspective is exactly
what we need where
you grew up uh you know rough uh
background saw your father pass i
believe at a young age
shifted around moved around had trouble
in school uh were sent to military
school for
a while which was a code i i thought for
like
you know this kid can't stop getting
into trouble
[Laughter]
um and then you went to a junior college
uh and then uh transferred to hopkins
wound up a rhodes scholar and then this
is what the turn i love so much is that
you wound up working
in finance but then you self-ejected out
of there and became an
army ranger a paratrooper where you then
uh uh became a decorated combat veteran
um instead of doing what frankly like 99
percent of people in that circumstance
do which is just try and
stay near the money tree and and have
have some of like the
um you know the fruit of the money tree
drop on your
your head and then convince yourself
that it was all because of how awesome
you were
um so then you you went uh after coming
back from from the military
um wrote multiple best-selling books
including the other wes moore that i
think they use in
schools around the country i became a
host on oprah
and then when you and i were in your
office you're the ceo of one of the
biggest
poverty fighting organizations in the
world robin hood which handles
like bajillions of dollars like how much
you guys give away in like a given year
yeah i mean a given year we'll do
anywhere from
you know 150 to 200 in in its existence
robin hood is giving away
uh north of three billion dollars to the
poverty fight yeah when you hear 150
like you might be thinking thousand he's
talking about millions
this organization uh gives away
hundreds of millions of dollars on the
regular two organizations in new york
city uh that's like the the domain
and so when you and i were talking
so to me your perspective is similar to
mine in that you sort of
headed all the way up into the uh belly
of the beast or like the heights
of high finance and now massive
philanthropy one of the most impactful
philanthropies in the world
and even you're looking at it being like
this is not enough
like we need to go much much bigger
if we're going to address these problems
in communities
uh not just in new york but around the
country yeah
and but but frankly and you know and um
um i am
very i'm very humbled by the work that
we're doing i'm
really excited about the work that we're
involved in right now and how robinhood
has just continued to
to push the needle on a lot of really
important issues
and not just with our funding with our
voice whether our advocacy with our
partnerships and all these other
respects
but but we also have to move with a
sense of humility
in the idea that you cannot come up with
million-dollar solutions to
trillion-dollar problems
yes hallelujah so i mean like we have to
be
we have to be clear about the enemy
that we have here and and how big and
how broad and how entrenched oftentimes
it is and so you know we we cannot you
know
and one thing i always you know talk
about with robin hood
is you know i when people say you know
how big is the charity you know
i say i don't i don't call what we do
charity i think charity is paternalistic
and it's offensive
right i think what we're not a charity
we're a change organization
you know we believe in changing the
fundamental structures of the society in
which we existed
and there is no patchwork solutions
to being able to address the fact that
we have long-term structural breaks
in the way we think about everything
from housing to the way we think about
transportation
to the way we think about education to
the way we think about justice reform
to the way we think about health mental
and physical health i mean all of these
aspects
play into this idea that we have to just
reframe and rethink things
when it comes to the policy mechanisms
that we're going to support and endorse
and also about how we're thinking about
the free usage of capital
within our society who needs it who gets
it
when do they get it and how can we think
use that as a way of creating true
measures and levers
of sustainable economic mobility for
families
yeah i know robin hood is all about
measurements you know when we were
in touch uh the very beginning of the
pandemic um we were talking about just
trying to get economic relief out to
people
and sometimes people ask me like hey how
did you measure
what the thousand uh recipients in the
bronx did with a thousand dollars each
um that they received and i was frank i
was like i'm like
i'm totally confident that the money
went to the good things like we did not
follow the people around we don't have
uh
you know phds studying what they did
with a thousand dollars we were just
very very confident that if you were a
struggling family in the bronx the
beginning of the pandemic
um on food stamps or otherwise like if
we give you a thousand dollars it's
gonna go to something
uh positive i'm telling andrew it's and
it's it's one of these things because we
are
uh we are a very data-driven
organization i'm a very data-driven
leader like i believe
in data deeply i also know this
is that uh you know the while we can
literally put a quantifiable
return roi on each dollar that's
investing to organizations because we
literally structure that in the way we
think about our investments you know
when to hear people make this argument
of well but if we give
you know the money to individuals what
are they going to spend it on
like we have to learn that you can be
you
you can be generous and not judgmental
yeah right
that we are talking about families who
are in some of the deepest most dire
situations if you took a look at new
york alone
in the past and this is research that we
do we have a partnership with columbia
university to create something called
the poverty tracker
which is really a longitudinal data set
for 4 000 families that we follow and
you can get kind of real-time
uh trend trend analysis right
here's what we found that half of new
yorkers
have been have have have suffered the
impacts of poverty for at least a year
over the past four years this was pre
covered 19.
not half of a borough not half of a
demographic group
half of the city has been in poverty for
at least a year
over the past four years so we're not
talking about a new phenomenon that
we're dealing with they're talking about
that
that that half of the city is enduring
the pain of poverty on a daily basis
and and you know of the many things that
i'm i'm truly truly proud of
that how this organization has been able
to move and mobilize in this moment
uh i think about the work that we were
able to do with the with the relief fund
and it goes back directly to
not just what you were talking about but
in many ways the thesis that you've been
arguing for years
right is that you know if so at the
onset of covert 19
at the author of the pandemic you know
we reactivated the robinhood relief fund
which was to support the highest need
new yorkers who were impacted by
covenant 19
and really prioritize the new yorkers
that have been
left out of federal aid responses such
as
low-income children and families
immigrant communities
college students low-wage workers
because people forget
even when you look at the cares act and
people say well wasn't there a cash
assistance element to the cares act
yes but millions of people were left out
of it people miss so many people
i mean and and in a very in a very in a
very intentional way
andrew it's like so people were
undocumented
despite them even being workers and
taxpayers they didn't benefit from
cash assistance if you were part of a
mixed status family
you didn't benefit from cash assistance
if you were working but not making
enough
to maintain in pains of taxes you didn't
benefit at all that pains me the most
that's exactly right at like the income
uh tax filing threshold uh the other one
that pains me is uh students if you're a
young student
exactly you didn't benefit you didn't
you didn't benefit from this
and so we had a federal policy that was
put into place but that intentionally
left out in many
communities who were oftentimes you know
the most vulnerable and and
we were prioritizing those who were most
impacted by the vast
racial and health disparities that have
been exacerbated by kobe 19.
75 percent of new york's low wage of new
york's low-wage workers
you know called to stay on the front
lines of the pandemic were people of
color
are our essential workers and so when we
thought about
how can we quickly mobilize
cash and assistance uh you know and we
think about the fact that even since the
pandemic began since the
onset we've now allocated over 37
million dollars
and just in that time period alone or
made over 500 grants
to over 430 organizations so i mean so
we've been moving fast to get cash in
and cash out the door
but one of the things that we were able
to do working with the community and
through the community
to identify what some of the greatest
needs were some of the greatest needs
were basic cash assistance yes basic
cash assistance where
you know 46 46 you know percent
of our grants that we made in that
throughout relief fund
were to provide emergency cash
assistance for
low-income new yorkers to cover
necessities and
and we weren't asking them to fill out
theses to explain
what were your necessities what are you
going to do with it
we need to see receipts no what we're
saying is
here's support god speed and we want to
make sure that this does not have to
become something that just becomes a
repetitive
process that these families and these in
these communities are then forced to
endure
and so how to rethink this whole process
how we're thinking
you know philanthropies role in this
became a really important and speedy
exercise
that not just us but also you know we
watched a lot of other organizations
take real leadership in it and it was it
was it was really great to see
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode